christina applegate after the SAG Awards
for those who don't know while we're
talking about he has pin and the leftist
outrage she just went on a Twitter
meltdown we've seen a lot of these but I
think this one is important to note
because it follows the SAG Awards and I
don't like Christina Applegate she wrote
I guess someone told her she shouldn't
be out there spewing her ignorant
political point and she wrote I find it
so offensive when people say those of us
can't talk you talk you spew so I'm
exempt because I chose my work what the
f you seek I don't want to give Jared
some censor work right now weird to me
when you say I can have a voice I'm also
a mother a daughter and a human I was
birthed the same way you were uh okay
see that there yeah men can get pregnant
to comment misstep but she did it you do
not assume how someone was birthed you
don't know and this is something I
guarantee you here some tweets upset
about that she went there and this comes
on the heels of someone sent you a
Twitter message saying shut up that's
about it right and she's acting like I
just can't believe well listen it pales
in comparison to the support you have
from the Hollywood elite who feel that
it's their job to speak up feel that
it's almost their fiduciary duty to the
shareholders they see as film goers that
they believe that you're paying them in
order to hear their political world view
so let's just do it do a highlight reel
of the SAG Awards from this weekend good
evening fellow sag AFTRA members and
everyone at home and everyone in
airports that belong in my america
cheers I love that sound of a hollow
chest yes like there's no tissue there
it's just a carcass and right away as he
was doing that
Jared pointed this out and I get here to
point us out as he was saying that it
was like the director said lean ethnic
shots quick quick quick quick quick
quick
I could beat the team I don't know what
that means and and let's just roll
really quickly because then I want to
get into the point of this the cast of
stranger things of course was the one
that was viral they were well they were
force trending on YouTube and HuffPo for
those who don't know this is the
director I believe or producer writer
stranger things also plays sergeant or
detective hopper this was his speech and
the casual violence of certain
individuals and institutions we will as
per chief Jim hopper punch some people
in the face when dealing with casual
violence they don't see it you know
we're gonna punch them in the face we
will take this well no one's asking you
to burden this we don't want you to
speaking of burden I don't know what is
on one no no we writers - rewind you
this is her during that speed you who
take your crafting can change the world
is to go deeper and through our art to
battle the words they're making
sentences is an exclusivity of our
predominantly narcissistic culture more
empathetic and understanding by
revealing
[Music]
it's it's sad what percocet does to
former shoplifters if you listen to the
whole stranger thing speech you listen
to sag sorry Winona Ryder Christina
Applegate was saying you know I don't
want people tell me that I can't speak
up no one's telling you you can't speak
up and you've listened to these speeches
that are going we will take this
responsibility as though it's been
bestowed upon them no one hasn't been
bestowed upon me you can speak up just
like everyone in the country can speak
up people do people do speak up on a
regular basis but you actually consider
it your job to speak up when you are
paid for something else and people will
have an opinion in response to that and
this is the only occupation that I know
of in the world where you are paid for
one service and you expect to be paid
for your political points of view you
were paid to act you are paid to sing
people want when they're buying that
ticket when they are downloading that
song they are effectively hiring you
every single time and they are hiring
you to create more content to create
more art you're an artist
why don't you embrace it you're not a
thinker you're not particularly smart
people as you see with no no writer
that's a look you do not want to see
you're coming down a dark alley listen
you think people elsewhere in the world
they have professions and um yeah at the
workplace people do have opinions on
politics but it's it's not the same kind
of expression
say if you think Trump's gonna pick for
the the old SCOTUS could go either way I
guess we'll see I guess we will see and
that's it yep done
nowhere else outside of the
entertainment industry do people feel
entitled to behave at their workplace
the way you do Trump you're gonna bring
up that racist sexist xenophobic
homophobic Islamophobic piece of you're
fired
hey if you liked this video subscribe by
clicking the button that says subscribe
if you're not aware of it now there's no
way you're learning the internet at this
point I'm not going to help you but this
was clipped from my daily show available
exclusively to lata with credit com /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than $6 a month and you
get daily content no more clips Plus
this hand edge mug oh I just when I feel
it I got a chill like on the inside